our buddy from cbs and he's got his own
local radio show uh down in the great
city of balmer
none other than jason lock and foreign
how are you jason
hey what's going on what's going on with
you what's up with you
living the dream man why not right you
know is this is this
is this a quiet time or is this a time
where do your phones not burn up as much
right now or the fact that we're in the
uh
uh franchise tag period hurting hurtling
inexorably towards uh a new league year
but no combine well
is this kind of a downtime a little bit
jason
um well i mean normally it would be you
know i think in in normal times we would
be in indianapolis we were on our way to
indianapolis there'd be plenty of that
going on we would know what the cap
is and there'd be um a fair amount of
activity
so it's i guess it's a little bit of a
calm before the storm but
you know as we know there's going to be
um
a lot of guys let go over the coming
weeks um eventually we will have more
certainty on exactly what um teams
will you know have in front of them in
terms of economic parameters
and the business of football uh the
business of football certainly
marches on i i think this will be a
different offseason in terms of
access to facilities and even players
and facilities
um and we may never get back to the days
of you know media in
two or three days a week through the
entire spring with otas
you know all that stuff um might go by
the wayside
um but yeah it's it's busy i mean
obviously anytime
you've got the potential for a
blockbuster quarterback traders
we've already had a couple and more
could be a foot and you know this big
ben
thing uh it's not put to bed yet
and and alex smith so
yeah i i guess relatively speaking rich
it's it's a little less
crazy than other times of the year but
we're about to get there well in your
answer to my macro question in your
preamble you
you mentioned a few things with big ben
and alex smith and other quarterbacks of
the monster trade and i want to get to
those
but before that normally i don't like to
talk about the business of football
because i don't know how many
fans are terribly into the the business
aspect of it but the business
aspect of it does actually affect
whether
somebody like say juju smith shuster is
going to be retained i've got chris
godwin on
in hour number three or the fact that
von miller could be cut or things like
that based on the salary cap and
you know and i'm just wondering about
the cap and
and how it's affected uh when when are
we going to find this out one winner one
of g
jason light on yesterday he said good
question when i asked when he's going to
know
what the the number is because it is
going to be appreciably lower than
expected correct due to covet 19
i mean i think it's a thing do i think
it's as big of a thing as teams are
making it out to be are they hiding
behind it a little bit
kind of waiting for others to blink and
and also knowing that
except for these rare occasions where
we're talking about specific
quarterbacks and specific contracts
that are probably only going to be moved
to a couple of places you know by and
large
i think most teams are content to let
things play out even the franchise tag
period itself nobody
feels the need to run out there and slap
a tag on somebody the first moment that
you can
um but is it something that
you know it two weeks from now becomes
an eventuality sure but
i mean look the cap is going to be
somewhere between 185 and
190 ish and and uh i guess
maybe a little higher if if things go
completely crazy and some of these tv
deals and they get done
um in short order but i i don't know how
you could bank on that but i
i think at this point if you're
projecting around 185
give or take a few million either way
you're you're going to be
in the ballpark uh but i think it's more
about well
what they haven't cut their guys yet
then we're not going to start cutting
our guys and
you know what would this whole sort of
you know
game of chicken that played sometimes
where
the teams certainly that are in cap
compliance and don't have to worry about
redoing a bunch of contracts right under
the cap
you know i i think for them it's
business as usual
and but they have the uh the wherewithal
to be patient to let these other teams
slowly have their bloodletting
to then start digging through that sort
of
um pile to find their treasure so uh
the 185 would be um how how
how how much less than what they would
expect 10 million 15 million i mean
that's that's a significant amount of
money
i mean if you were continuing to just
project forward with how the cap would
be moving then it would be
considerably less but if you you'd also
you know if that's how you were
operating rich and shame on you no
i know this pandemic i hear you you saw
you know a season with no people in the
stands by and large
um so this was going to be something
that was going to impact the 2021
season and especially the economics of
the 2021 season
to great regard and the reality is the
league year starts in
in the middle of march and we weren't
going to be fully
vaccinated by then we weren't going to
have a whole lot of assurances
by then about what stadiums are
absolutely positively going to look like
you know in august in september of of
this year
so i i mean i you would be kind of
grossly negligent to have been
operating internally and anything other
than okay
it's going to be in the 180s i hear you
it's just
last one on this before we move on uh
are you saying that the current tv deal
negotiations if they come through
might actually affect this salary cap
right here right now because
what you're hearing is that uh you know
uh my
current bosses your former bosses are
are asking uh
so much for monday night football that
uh jerry jones might personally own mr
toad's wild ride in
both theme parks on both coasts by the
end of this conversation
uh yeah i i think um
you know there's a negotiate active
negotiations going on
um my bosses your bosses a lot of
people's bosses
uh trying to figure out exactly what the
right number is and what makes sense
for them um and i think some of these
deals are probably
further along than others um
could it affect the cap right yeah right
more future call certainty you have and
revenue certainty you have
the easier it is tomorrow against
tomorrow
to make the pot bigger today um
eventually they may run out of time
you know and it just may be it is what
it is um
but i have found in my experience
that even in normal years you would have
the salary cap negotiators and
front office people go down to dallas
for the nfl management council meetings
around thanksgiving
and they come back with the number and
then the nfl pa
and the league would meet at the combine
to set the final number
and that number would invariably be much
higher than sort of the worst case
scenario that would be issued to the
teams
you know three months prior so where
there's a will there's a way and it's in
everybody's best interest to do it
um but do i think we're going to look at
a scenario where it's at
one you know it's pushing 200 you know i
i just
i i don't i think we're starting to run
out of time
for that but if you're projecting again
185 maybe they goose it to 190 ish
you know could that cost you a player i
mean is that a significant difference
for some teams more than others
especially the ones that are 30 million
over right but by and large for the rest
of the week i think it just creates like
i said an environment where
we don't need to rush out and do
anything let's let this market
settle all right jason lochen forum cbs
sports nfl insider here on the rich
eisen show we started the show by uh and
also in your your preamble a few moments
ago uh that the big ben
meeting with art rooney the second the
president of the steelers went down
yesterday called
a statement today from from the owner
basically said
ben wants to be here we'd like him to be
here we both agree though we got to find
the number what's the number what's the
number to uh to keep big ben
um in the fold him happy team happy etc
so on and so forth what's that number
well i don't think it's 19 million
dollars next year
richer we wouldn't be having you know
multiple
press conferences and zoom meetings
right you know
statements coming out every 12 to 24
hours
and and really everyone's kind of tap
danced around this
but the the sort of awkward messy
uncomfortable conversations
haven't taken place yet and i can see
why neither party
would want to dive in and and entertain
that product
well what are those is it more than
money is that what you're inferring well
no i mean i think it's it's it's clearly
money i mean
it's absolutely money it's how much is
guaranteed it's how much are you paid
this year it's how much is rolled into
incentives
likely to be earned or not likely to be
earned it's sort of the
how you know the the the ingredients of
the sausage and
and how it gets made and this isn't if
this was a simple
we're gonna give you all your money
we're going to give it to you up front
now instead of you earning it over 17
paychecks
and we're going to convert it to a bonus
and add two avoidable years
that's going to be a conversation that
would just be a paper transaction that
the steelers could have executed at any
point
but colbert we're not talking about it
you know in late february
right but colbert basically uh the
general manager
uh wouldn't allow anything other than
the fact that he's currently a human
being under contract which is really
weird and now but it so what would be
the alternative they're going to run up
run it back with mason rudolph that
they're that they hope that dwayne
haskins who they acquired
um you know uh a couple weeks ago
is is going to turn things around and
and be the guy to
to try and beat a a a a res
a surging browns team or a ravens team
that does appear to be
set now year in and year out with lamar
i mean like clearly ben's the
the uh pushing for pushing 40 ben
for the steelers right here right now as
they got way to like what
what's the alternative if the number's
not found they got to find a number is
basically what i'm
essentially landing on with you right
now yeah or no am i off
no i i mean i i their number might not
be his number
i'm sure like what if their numbers 12
and his number is 16. i mean i'm just
throwing it
clearly ownership doesn't want to pay
this guy 19 million dollars
like that's so i don't know how you
could look at this scenario and say
that that isn't one obvious sort of
takeaway from how this is played out um
and the numbers probably fairly
significantly below 19
or we still wouldn't be playing this
word game a month after the season
you know what i mean not really wanting
to dive into the meat and potatoes but
talking around it
i don't know what the number is i'm not
even sure if it's been
absolutely stated to um the employees of
the steelers will have to go about
negotiating this compromise but
there is clearly some reservation
about that level of compensation for
this player
given what they saw in the second half
of last year
and my suspicion is someone who's
covered a lot of these things as
again if this was a million bucks or a
couple of million bucks
i don't think you and i are having this
conversation trying to read tea leaves i
think it's
i think it's a done deal now maybe
they'll get together with his
representation
and it'll be done in an hour or a couple
of hours i
it hasn't happened yet so i don't know
but
they have set this up to be something
very different
than all their previous kick the can
down the road nothing to see here
um we're just converting uh future money
into present-day money and we're
changing it from
base salary to roster you know bonus
and signing bonus and you know
right we don't even need we can just do
it over the phone jason lock and for
here on the rich eisen show let's let's
uh let's do some quick hitters
um just a couple weeks ago sir where you
uh
threw out there on your twitter feed
that uh russell wilson's been sacked in
a
a bunch of a bunch of times you threw
the number out there and you said that
this
bears close monitoring and then
you know uh russell wilson was on uh dp
show
uh mentioning he sort of essentially
saying yeah
this should be monitored um and
uh are there calls coming to seattle for
russ like what
what is actually cooking there that
could lead to something other than
the uh the assumed uh
role that russell has had there in
seattle continuing
um yeah i mean look at everybody
ultimately has a price there's a price
on every
professional athlete's head in terms of
trade compensation whether it's stated
or unstated
whether it's known um because they've
had internal discussions about it among
the people who
currently pay his checks or or whether
it's
you know art i'll know it when i see it
you know when i hear it
it'll it'll happen um i'll that will be
enough
for us to say wait a minute door b is
better than
what we currently have in door a
especially because things between us and
the guy
on the other side of door a just aren't
rosy right now and and you know maybe
won't
be imminently more rosy anytime soon
so i think that's just something that
you know it's a lot of time between now
in the draft and
teams had been hearing rumblings of
discontent there before
i heard it i started hearing it the
weekend of super bowl sunday and then
i did more digging in the more i did the
more it was clear to me that there was
some real there there and then as you
said russ basically confirmed everything
and for us to speak the way russ spoke
um knowing him knowing sort of how
um guarded he can be and and how
calculated he would be about what he
says and what he doesn't say and how
close he'll go
to towing certain lines and how much he
won't
i thought it spoke volumes and that just
intensified
the calls from other teams and i don't
think that it will
necessarily let up anytime soon and at
some point does somebody
say something that john schneider and
pete carroll kind of
jump up from their seats and and talk
about and strongly consider
i mean i don't see why that's
an impossibility well it's because gino
smith's there jason
i mean and i say that with the ultimate
respect like uh
what i mean and that's what's so
surprising a lot of people i've heard
rumors to that effect way back even to
the draft in dallas where baker mayfield
was the first round draft choice keep an
eye out
for seattle maybe choosing a quarterback
i mean i
i've heard that for you but what is it
you got two insanely positive successful
guys and pete carroll
and russell wilson what what is the the
there that might be there
for i mean look uh you know when when
they had boots on the ground watching
josh allen
you know a personal workout that caught
some people's attention and they did a
deal few years ago
i'm old enough to remember that wasn't
just a hand sliding into a glove
that was a long arduous process that
took some twists and turns and had
periods of time where
one side or the other was you know
incommunicado
uh that was a staccato process that
wasn't exactly linear
and and wasn't as simple
frankly as a lot of franchise
quarterback extensions are
um look he's not getting any younger and
he's still getting hit a lot
and here we're in an era where players
are seeing with increasing regularity
that that they can kind of rattle change
a little bit
and and they they can um yep
have more of a say in what's going on
around them and how
they're incubated or how they're not
incubated um and how
assets are deployed and he's seeing
these guys 10 years older than him one
guy in particular
continually fight for a super bowl and
and kind of call his own shot like babe
ruth pick a team and win a super bowl
uh and you kind of start looking around
and feeling
10 years in your football mortality a
little bit and if you truly want to be
that great um and you feel like there's
certain things you need to get there
that
they don't seem to really want to give
you or certain
um you know a certain sort of level
of voice or ownership of the situation
that you don't feel like you've been
granted with each year that goes by and
things don't necessarily change
then that frustration can mount and i
think that's
kind of where we are right now and is it
completely untenable no um
but i you know why why was it weird a
couple years ago you know what i mean
why
hasn't it gone as swimmingly as some
some other
um of these situations when you have a
guy who's that good
last i don't i don't know that i exactly
know
right um but it's sort of a thing you
know it is a
lingering thing it keeps going on last
one for you jason
um you know this one surprised me
um alex smith telling gq uh essentially
that um washington didn't want him there
he kind of put a wrench in
in their plans by um by actually
still trying to play football and
interestingly enough that wrench was
quite a crucial tool for them uh
yeah you know in the second half of the
season that they hoped that they could
use with all
due respect to taylor heineke but they
didn't see it
didn't want me there didn't want me to
be a part of it didn't want me to be on
the team the roster didn't want to give
me a chance
what do you make of all that jason just
found
1400 words on that little a couple
minutes ago it should be up at cbs
sports
dot com um a little later this afternoon
i'm not surprised by any of it i think
that
um you know the professional sports is a
meat grinder
um there are issues of
roster clarifications and stipulations
and their salary caps and there's
guaranteed money
and they're sort of these factors that
um can kind of thrust
people together and it was his contract
that kept this thing thrust together
if bruce allen didn't give him that
extension which even at the time people
thought
was a little bit exorbitant and if it
didn't have that much guaranteed money
going that far into the future
that must be real right ron revere's
coming in it's a new program
he's kind of saddled with this haskins
thing he's battling cancer it's in a
pandemic
and he brings this system guy kyle allen
along it becomes pretty clear by week
two that kyle allen's gonna play
football really really soon
and that they want kyle allen to be the
guy and then at the same time there's
also alex smith doing this incredible
thing but doing this incredible thing
that the medical community and the
football world are like
you know like we've never seen anything
like this before we don't know exactly
how this is going to go
and you know it might not be feasible he
he might not be able to do all the
things you have to do
over the course of these months in a
pandemic to actually be able to play
football this year
um so i i'm not really surprised
by it in the least uh it may surprise
some people that alex smith
said it i think he's every right to say
it and he should say it's
part of his story so i guess in the in
the 30 seconds that i have
a marriage of convene you know what i
mean this was a marriage that was sure
born of things that predated
this arrival this these guys in this
organization and
you know there wasn't a whole lot of kid
glove stuff going on with haskins i'm
i'm not surprised that they weren't
investing every waking moment in this
recovery
because we're trying to build a
long-term thing here and this guy's 36
and he's not really going to be a part
of that right exactly so i guess i've
got 30 seconds left
uh is alex smith a player to to put on
this carousel as a free agent in the nfl
or stay in washington right now i i
don't think you know i never thought
it'd be back in washington
um i i don't it was a tough you know
he overcame a lot there's if you watch
them play closely there's a lot of
limitations there i mean doesn't andy
reid
or does an urban meyer somebody like
that who know and bring him in in some
capacity
i think sure um him playing week in week
out
at this stage i i don't know about that
rich thanks for the call jason you take
care
you got it buddy have a good one that's
jason lock and floor hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here